التاريخ المنشود قد حل حظر الاتحاد
الاوروبي ودول السبعه على الصادرات روسيا
من النفط ومشتقاته دخل حيز التنفيذ ومعه
تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي بنحو 60
دولارا للبرميل فما الذي يعنيه برميل
النفط الروسي ليتم تداوله باعلى من 60
دولارا للبرميل في وقت يصل فيه السعر
المرجعي اي متوسط سعر البرميل حاليا لنحو
79 دولارا فهل تطبيق العقوبات ممكن
وبسهوله الاجابه المقتضبه ممكن ولكن يتعين
بدايه اقناع اكبر مستهلكين نفط الخام
الروسي الصين والهند بالموافقه على الحظر
والسقف السعري
الصين وهي اكبر مستورد للنفط الخام الروسي
باكثر من مليون برميل يوميا والهند
تقاربها من حيث معدل الاستيراد والدولتان
اصلا تنالان معامله تفضيليه من روسيا
روسيا مسؤوله عن انتاج قرابه عشره ونصف في
المئه من النفط الخام عالميا وهي كميه قد
تكون مؤثره في تحقيق اهداف العقوبات
فالطلب العالمي مرشح للارتفاع خاصه مع
انتعاش الاقتصاد الصيني والاستثمارات
العالميه في مشاريع الطاقه الاحفوريه سجل
التراجعا ملموسا فماذا لو قررت روسيا وقف
صادرتها تلقائيا او الالتفاف على العقوبات
سيدخل الاقتصاد العالمي في ازمه ارتفاع
اسعار النفط وبالتالي ينعكس ذلك على اسعار
السلع والخدمات وستبقى الدول المستفيده
تلك التي تتعامل مع روسيا الصين والهند
وغيرهما يمكن للهند مثلا او دوله اخرى
للالتفاف على العقوبات بفتح باب خلفي
للنفط الروسي تستورده تكرره وتعيد بيعه مع
الاخذ في الاعتبار ان موسكو تؤكد انها
ستتخذ التدابير الحمائيه اللازمه لكن
العقوبات اثرت بالطبع لعائدات موسكو من
النفط والغاز سجل الشهر الماضي انخفاضا
بنحو 30% مقارنه بالفتره نفسها العام
الماضي وخسرت روسيا قرابه ثمانيه مليارات
دولار الا ان تقارير اقتصاديه تقول انه من
المرجح تلاشي اثار العقوبات بمرور الوقت
فمن سيصرخ اولا روسيا ام اقتصاد السوق